a 42-second video clip released by The
Pentagon shows a Russian su-27 fighter
plane dumping what is said to be jet
fuel into the path of a U.S Reaper
surveillance drone
High over the Black Sea it makes a
second pass repeating the process and
then we're told the plane makes contact
with the drone's tail propeller the
video feed cuts out
resuming 60 seconds later to reveal a
damaged propeller blade
afterwards the drone's remote Pilots
bring it down in the waters of the Black
Sea the Pentagon said it would not be
deterred by what it said was a pattern
of risky Behavior by Russian pilots in
international airspace in the United
States
will continue to fly and to operate
wherever international law allows
and it is incumbent upon Russia to
operate his military aircraft
in a safe and professional manner
Russia's foreign minister said the U.S
drone had not in fact been in
international airspace
they totally ignore the fact that after
the start of the special military
operation our military declared that
certain areas of the Black Sea had
limited access by any aerial vehicles
and this defiant neglect of that
objective fact makes one think the
American side keeps looking for
provocations to fuel confrontation
the Ukrainian military has reported
unusual levels of activity by Russian
ships in the Black Sea a possible
scramble to recover the wreckage the
southwest of the Crimean peninsula where
we know this drone went down that's more
or less below Odessa the Ukrainian city
that was you know threatened it's not
far from where the muscover Russian
warship was sunk back in April so I
think there's there's a big concern in
the US that they'll be able to continue
to mount these valence operations
without this kind of thing happening
again Russia has denied any wrongdoing
and initially blamed the incident on a
faulty maneuver by The Reaper drone its
retrieval could provide valuable
intelligence the aerial encounter was
the first known military contact between
the U.S and Russia since the war in
Ukraine began reinforcing widely held
concerns that the two superpowers could
eventually be drawn into direct conflict
Jonah Hull Al Jazeera